E aí
[Música]
em 2013 viviam no porto estava
desempregada e pensei o que é que vou
fazer agora um dia decidi vou ser
organizer eu vou ajudar as pessoas a
organizar a casa espaço trabalho mas
ninguém sabia o que faz uma organizaç
e eu comecei por organizar a minha casa
e que sou bem seguida tentei a casa dos
amigos não gostei nada bem depois tentei
escritórios e hora ainda até que um dia
enviei uma proposta do workshop para uma
cadeia de lojas que vende produtos para
arrumação da casa e poucas semanas
depois eu e a minha amiga Isabel
Rodrigues está vamos apresentar o outro
choques nas principais lojas desta marca
do norte a sul do país
e eu falava sobre organização da casa e
Ciel Rodrigues que é licenciada em
contabilidade palavra sobre organização
financeira não sermos a dupla perfeita
adorar vamos trabalhar juntas e melhor
ainda éramos pagas para isso
bom e foi nessa altura que eu criei o
projeto organizar com Lígia em poucos
dias a minha página do Facebook aumentou
de 800 seguidores para quase 3 mil
quando o primeiro workshop foi divulgado
eu queria falar sobre organização da
casa e como deixar tudo perfeito
existentes tem uma que deixar as pessoas
de mais curiosas ainda cada vez que eu
falava sobre esse tema As pessoas
movimentaram o corpo ligeiramente para a
frente os olhos ficavam muito best e
muito atentas a que estava Assiste esse
tema é destralhar Afinal o que é
destralhar
a destralhar a retirada das nossas casas
aqui nós não precisamos o que nós não
gostamos o que não tem utilidade e
apenas está que faz passo
e com Thaís Godinho Não Existe maneira
de organizar o que é #o segredo é
livrar-se da tralha até exame organizer
é brasileira e tem um bloco que eu gosto
muito de chama-se vida organizada eu
percebi que a grande maioria das pessoas
tem dificuldade em separar se os objetos
que não precisa e quando isso acontece
torna-se difícil tomar decisões entre
decidir o que é que é mesmo essencial e
o que apenas está a passo e quando isso
acontece o que é que nós fazemos
guardamos tudo que tem que se um dia
poderemos precisar
Rio 2016 modem pra cá mais com a minha
família acalmar em uma pequena cidade ao
sul da Suécia em kalmar seguir continuar
o meu sonho é ser organizar mas surgiu
exatamente o mesmo problema ninguém
sabia o que faz uma organização eu
comecei por apresentar palestras e
cursos sobre dicas de organização da
casa até que um dia tive direito ao meu
momento de fama encalmar uma reportagem
na Jornal Local que se chama acalmar
Costa com o título Lígia ensina as
pessoas acalmar a organizaç
bom e com grande destaque para o meu
trabalho e o método de armário Conde
armário com tu és japonesa é organizar e
tornou-se muito conhecida pela Soneto de
organização a maricondi defendo que
devemos guardar apenas os objetos nos
fazem sentir feliz que nos trazem
alegria caso contrário devemos dizer
obrigada e adeus para sempre então que
estava eufórica por este momento e
queria partilhar com a minha família que
o erro na madeira tirei uma foto a
postagem e o que é pelo WhatsApp o grupo
da família como resposta recebi duas
mensagens a primeira que dizia parabéns
e segunda mensagem que dizia
a ação está melhor ela está no hospital
a oração é a minha irmã faz 55 anos
sofreu um AVC ou segundo os médicos
foram vários
todos os dias melhorada os dias esperava
um dia ficou em estado vegetativo
o recebimento ao cinema Lígia transferir
a madeira não sabemos se Alberto comprar
e depois Alguém disse prepara vai ficar
muito chocado ao dela e eu preparei que
estava na madeira Mas queria estar lá
para apoiar a família
É porque era o momento de ligar para
toda a gente
e no dia que chegar a madeira foi
visitar a minha irmã no hospital e para
quem nunca tive oportunidade de visitar
um familiar nesta situação é um momento
em que não seja ninguém é uma grande
mistura de pensamentos e sentimentos que
é será que ela está ouvir a minha voz
será que aquela lágrima foi intencional
já que o movimento das pernas significa
alguma coisa já que ela está a tentar
comunicar conosco
bom então como eu imaginava que o
momento chocante e marcante mas eu
estava preparada
é o que eu não estava preparada foi para
entrar em casa de ação
e eu entrei lá apenas para ajudar a
retirar algumas coisas do frigorífico
desligar o frigorífico seria uma tarefa
muito simples
e quando entrei em casa da são estava
tudo exatamente como estava desde a
última vez que ela saiu para ir ao
hospital
a versão estava no hospital há cerca de
um mês e
e seria uma visita curta isso ela e tudo
ficou à espera dela
e lembro-me que na mesa da sala estava
PC aberto uma distância diabetes livros
de história abertas ação era professora
de história muitas canetas coloridas
muito poste escritos à mão
e os textos dos alunos
A Espera de serem corrigidos
e eu fiquei em silêncio
é apenas pensava ação não volta para
casa e esta frase repetir muitas vezes
na minha cabeça
e na cozinha estava muitas notas
escritas à mão feitas ao pensas que
feitas que um dia ela gostaria de
cozinhar muitos livros por toda a casa
ação aturava ler muitas lembranças de
viagem ação adorava viajar
a e nesse momento pensei a vida é isto
um dia Saímos de casa e nunca mais
iremos voltar
eu queria ela feliz aqui
E quando voltei para acalmar apresentei
a última parece uma semana depois e de
alguma forma senti que seria a última
vez que eu conseguiria falar sobre
organização da casa sobre organização
perfeita
já terminou o sonho em ser organizar
porque as redes sociais pelos livres e
até parei de dobrar as mangas pelo
método da Mary quant
o outro dia minha amiga Eva que é
portuguesa e bebê acalmar Veio cá a casa
buscar as filhas que está com cara
brincar e Eva é aquele tipo de mulher
que está sempre impecável todos os dias
e pior ainda tem a casa mais organizada
que eu conheço panela chegou disse para
as filhas já viu como é que está
arranjei isso e filha deve respondeu
Exatamente no mesmo só o mãe não fomos
nós que fizemos este já estava assim
quando chegamos e é de ferias bonecos da
Playmobil que estavam nesse momento a
fazer a sua viagem que todas são na sala
e eu gostava na cozinha hábito pensei
acho que não vou dizer nada vou fingir
que não vi porque agora eu quero ter uma
casa feliz e convida
e afinal o que é que é mesmo é
importante organizar quando eu sair de
casa e nunca mais voltar vou querer
deixar os documentos importantes
organizar this
eu vou deixar apenas as fotos que contam
histórias
eu vou deixar filmes vídeos com as
minhas cascalhadas e os meus comentários
e lembranças apenas lembranças de
momentos inesquecíveis e vou deixar o
plano do meu funeral e vai ser assim do
gênero como se vê nos filmes em que as
pessoas que conversam as coisas outros e
como em qualquer coisa
e vai ter música música dos Queen e quem
sabe a minha música favorita don't stop
me now vai que bolo bolo de chocolate e
café estilo adoro e é desta forma que
quer ser lembrada
a ação na volta para casa
e faleceu em julho de dois mil e
dezenove
é a grande questão tornou-se
Oi bom dia quando eu sair de casa e
nunca mais voltaste o cão sentir as
pessoas que eu mais amo ao entrar na
minha casa
e ninguém gosta muito de falar sobre
isto porque é difícil
já pensaste um dia a vida acaba
e eu considero que é importante repensar
as prioridades na nossa vida e fazer as
escolhas certas
bom e você um dia quando vocês sair de
casa e nunca mais voltar
E como está a sua casa
é perfeita e arrumada ou feliz e convida
é obrigado a